hello everyone.welcome I haven't even
done anything yet you're already
clapping that's great it sounds good
come on in you're all in the right spot
find a seat
it's great to see you all here you're
looking good
my name is Dan Roth I'm a program
manager on the asp.net team at Microsoft
and I'm super excited to be here at MDC
in this session we're going to be
talking about Razer components in
asp.net core 3 oh and so the big
exciting announcement happened yesterday
dotnet core 3 o preview 2 shipped with
Razer components in the box and I am
pumped about this this has been a long
time coming for me this has been stuff
that we've been working on for a year
year and a half you really go back in
history internally but even longer than
that so there's some pretty cool stuff
it's in this release it's not the only
thing that's in this release I encourage
you to go look at the the blog posts for
for pv2 and all the cool stuff that's in
asp.net core and dotnet core but in this
session will focus on Razer components
so what our Razer components or Racer
components allow you to build rich
interactive modern web UI without having
to write any JavaScript that's what they
do you can create reusable UI components
using c-sharp using dotnet and razor
syntax and they integrate with your
existing asp.net core applications now
that's that's a little high-level a
little abstract it's probably easier if
we just show you what we mean by by this
razor components thing so I'll demo
getting started with razor components
you can of course can now do this too
because all the bits are live and public
the things that you would need in order
to get started with razor components
you'll need to get the dotnet core 300
preview 2 SDK also going down though
that if you're on a Windows machine you
should also get the latest preview
release of Visual Studio 2019 preview 2
I believe is the the latest one the nice
thing is that the Razr components
tooling is built into Visual Studio at
that point so you don't need to go
install any additional v6s it's just
there in the box
so let's take our first look and what is
a razor component okay so getting
started how do you do that so you're
going to want to go to dot dot net
that's the magic URL for getting all
things net when you land on the dotnet
homepage click on download and at the
top you'll see there's a banner here it
says try out the latest dotnet core
preview a link on the right that's where
you're gonna get the three O preview two
SDK so download the SDK for whatever OS
are using Windows Mac Linux it all works
on all those platforms after you've done
that you're gonna want to go to visual
studio dot-com slash preview and then go
and download the latest Visual Studio
preview for those of you who are still a
little bit jittery about installing
Visual Studio previews I know in years
of past this was a dicey thing to do it
kind of meant you would probably have to
repave your machine if you installed a
preview version of Visual Studio
honestly the installation technology
with Visual Studio has gotten really
good the side by side installations work
really well I currently like let me get
my Visual Studio installer UI up I have
three versions of Visual Studio
installed side by side right now I have
2017 I have the preview release the
public preview of 2019 I've got some
crazy internal build of like the preview
3 version of 2019 and it works really
really well like I've been able to
uninstall and install them very cleanly
works great so I encourage you to do so
I typically install just the the web
work load in the.net core workload
because that's the stuff that I normally
work with all right so once you've got
that you'll have 2019 and you should be
ready to go to create your first race or
components app so I'm gonna select in
the new project dialog this is the new
UI in 2019 I want to create an asp.net
core web application
alright a razor components is under that
umbrella what should we call this let's
call it razor components demo I think I
haven't used that name yet all right and
so in the new a spec core dialog you can
see we've got a bunch of templates here
make sure that you've sold
I did three Oh at the top that will show
up after you've installed the 300 SDK
and there is a Razer components template
now I'm going to select that and go
ahead and create it cool all right once
this is created this is you notice it's
a solution has a server-side project and
in the actual app that contains my you I
will let the packages make sure they
shake out oh I didn't actually yeah I
got you I've got Network cuz I was able
to get to the dotnet website so that's
good alright so come the store is
completed let's go ahead and run it and
see what this application can do build
run run run this is where people usually
tell me Danny you need a new laptop man
and I say yeah yeah my boss is here you
go tell alright so this is a simple sort
of spa style application it's got tabs
on the left you can click on and see
various pages it also does routing on
the client so you can click back and
forth there's a page with just you know
some static content there's a counter
that you can click on a button in an
updates account there's no page refresh
happening there that's something that
normally you'd have to write some
JavaScript in order to accomplish but
there was no JavaScript used to write
this application I didn't have to write
any there's also this third page which
here it's actually getting a bunch of
weather forecast data on the server and
using that to then render this this
table of weather forecast information
alright so how did this all work how do
you write this let's look at those pages
if we go look at counter here's the
implementation of the counter page or
counter component there is a at page
directive at the top that says that this
particular
RAZR component is routable you can
browse the slash counter and you'll get
this component there's some just normal
HTML markup and then we use razor syntax
in order to get values and render them
to the page and these are all dotnet
values so we have a current count field
that's a type int and then there's our
button which has an onclick handler
which normally you could put some
JavaScript there to call but we're not
pointing at any JavaScript this is
actually pointing at a normal see sharp
dotnet method to then increment the
count so that's how that's done and to
this is actually what's what's running
let's go ahead and set a breakpoint I'm
gonna f5 run the app again
and let that come up and then see if we
can get that breakpoint to hit okay so
go to counter
let's click the count and voila so now
we're hitting our c-sharp code even
though there's no page refresh happening
there okay so that's that's part of the
beauty of razor components first of all
know no JavaScript but you get that rich
interactive feel what else can we do so
these are components that means that
they are reusable pieces of UI so let's
see if we can reuse some of our
components we've got at least three of
them here we have a counter component a
fetch data component and an index
component all written as raiser files
let's go into the index page I'm gonna
stop the debugger let's go and then
let's go ahead and try and reuse one of
our components let's try and put a
counter component right here on the home
page rerun so now I would expect that
would not only have a counter page but
also see the counter component show up
on the home page and I do and these are
independent things and click the counter
there I can click the counter here let's
put another components put a fetch data
component right here on the main page so
you use raiser components using normal
HTML element and attribute syntax
alright so now we've got a whole weather
forecast component on the same page as
our counter so these are reusable
composable pieces of UI and of course
all the normal razors syntax stuff
applies like if you wanted a whole bunch
of counters like we could do before and
I equals 0
well I is let's I put like 5 of them on
here I I plus boss and then put this in
a little loop and now we got more
counters then then I got to put make
sure I know my c-sharp there we go and I
did that backwards but who cares I think
it's over X right doesn't work on the
other side take a listen does the
opposite returns the value
so I just cancel it and let's try to do
that again with the right way and
hopefully now we get a whole bunch of
counters on the main page and there they
are so we got all these counters notice
that they each have their own state
right like you can count them
independently so that's pretty nice so
that's reusing components components can
also have parameters you can pass data
to the components that they can then use
as part of their rendering logic so
let's go to let's simplify this back
down to just counter and let's see if we
can add a parameter to our counter
component it's gonna go back to the
counter component and add a property and
the way you add parameters to components
is by creating properties that are
attributed with the parameter attribute
and let's create one called increment
amount and let's initialize it to say 1
and then down here we can use it for for
incrementing at different amounts okay
great and then on the home page let's
increment by some interesting amount
there you can see that the attributes
not showing up in intellisense so you
get great editor support lets akram it
by 10 on the home page and then on the
normal counter page that should still
increment by 1 because we didn't pass
any parameters there so the normal
counter page yep still incrementing by 1
on the home page increments by 10 okay
so that is parameters what else can you
do with components well these are
interactive pieces of UI so they have of
course event handlers you can handle any
user UI event that you want to in this
case I'm handling the onclick event for
the this button when you handle an event
you can you just need to specify a
delegate to the c-sharp code that you
want to have called that delegate can
take no parameters like this one is
currently doing or it can't take
additional parameters for example let's
say we wanted to actually know stuff
about like where it was clicked or was
the shift key held down those types of
things you can put in a parameter here
was it UI mouse event args I think is
the one for click events
then let's say that we will increment by
increment amount let's see if it's the e
shift key is pressed then we're going to
increment by like a hundred otherwise
we're going to increment by the normal
increment amount okay
so let's see if that works all right so
I click like click click it's going up
by tens because that's the parameter
that I specify for this component if I
hold down the shift key while I'm
clicking clicking clicking now it's
going up by a hundred so you can get all
the information about the what what
happened actually with that event now if
you don't this is the method group way
of specifying an event handler if you
prefer instead to use lambda syntax
that's cool too like if you want to do
something like this where you just say
current count plus equals increment
amount that's totally fine that should
work exactly the same way just to prove
that that this guy's not even getting
called will comment that out and see if
we go back to the other behavior and
yeah and Shift key doesn't do anything
at this point yeah so you can use Lander
syntax or method groups event handlers
can also be async so if you have a sync
logic that you want to put in your
events that's totally cool you can do
that as well
I actually prefer the methyl group
syntax so I'm gonna go back to that so
increment amount and we get nice and
tell a sense for your method groups and
select that and we're good okay so
that's event handling what about now
data binding like if you have data that
the user is typing into like say an
input and you want to capture that in
the dotnet world how do you do that that
supposed to be increment count that's
why it was complaining all right great
so what I'm gonna do now let's add
another page to this application and
we'll do the you know the simple to-do
list demo just so we can see how data
binding works and let's rename this file
to to do so I'm just creating another
component will erase all the stuff that
was in there and so we want this to be a
page so this is a component that's
routable so we're gonna add that page
directive again at the top and we'll say
that request to slash to do should end
about this page and then let's just add
a header here
and now some of this if you have been
watching following along with some of
the stuff that we've been doing with you
know components in the a steam some of
this may seem very familiar and that's
okay like that's very deliberate so if
you've seen this before
just hold on we will get there about why
we're doing this and that's alright
don't worry about that everything is
fine here this is our preview bit so
there are some some issues but okay so
currently there's no no tab showing up
because we haven't added our two to do
page to the layout but I should now be
able to go to just slash to do and voila
there's the to do page that I just
started to set up now I want this
component to have some state when we
want to manage a list of to-do items I
just get to write C sharp codes let's
add a class here to-do item and let's do
public class and add a couple properties
let's add a string title and a boolean
is done okay
and then I list of to-do item I think
that's because the editor had a little
issue so we'll give it a second to to
repent all right there we go to-do item
and then a new list of to-do items great
that'll be the state of our component to
be managing a list of two dues
what do we will have so we need to
render those two dues to the screen so
I'm going to create an unordered list
and just use normal razor syntax so for
each bar to do into dues we'll create a
just a list item here and will render
the current to do to do title okay so
first the until isn't showing up there
looks great alright now we don't have
any to do as yet so this won't actually
do anything we need a way to add some to
dues and that's where data binding comes
in so let's go ahead and add an input
down here at the bottom and we'll give
it a little placeholder do something
okay
and we want to bind the value of this
input to something in c-sharp plan so
I'm going to
a little string new to do and I'm going
to bind to new to do see that okay so
what does that do well bind is going to
do two things it'll listen to the on
change event for the input and when the
on change event happens it will set the
the value of whatever you bound to to
the current value of the input and also
when the input is rendered bind will
take care of rendering the value for
that input as the thing that you bound
to as the the new the new to do string
so it's a two-way bind alright and then
we just need something to say that we're
done with adding something so let's add
a button let's call it add and we need
to add an event handler for that so
that's at a add to do event and in here
we'll check if the if the value is not
an all or empty of the new to do then
we'll add a new one to the Tuzla so to
do add new to do item title equals the
value of that new to do and then let's
go ahead and clear out the new to do
string because we're done with it with
that particular value okay actually
probably want this to be not is null or
empty and then we need a wire up this
event handler to our button so the wire
up the event handler we saw that before
we just take the on click attribute and
we do at to say that we're calling in to
c-sharp not javascript here and we want
to say it's gonna go up there is two
okay I think I think that should do it
let's see if we want I think that will
work it still won't show up in our
layout yet let me rerun the app
hopefully do we got any build errors and
I missing these semicolons or anything
that actually looks like it might work
so let's browse to slash to do okay so
now let's see can we bind some data so
I'm gonna type something in the input
and click Add
and it's adding it to my list that's add
something else one thing I really need
to do is get some sleep that would be
great and there you go okay so that's a
simple to-do list app where your data
binding we could do even a little bit
more fancy data binding like instead of
just rendering out the the title I mean
this is to-do list right it's got to
have checkboxes so let's add an input of
type checkbox here we'll bind to the to
do is done property mm-hmm it's typing
at an Engel is kind of an interesting
exercise and then we'll create a text
box will also be able to bind to the to
the title in case we want to edit it so
to dude title and to show that these are
working let's show the count of how many
to-do items are not done yet up at the
top so we'll use some razor syntax here
to do is dot count and we'll filter the
two dues by the ones that are not done
and in parentheses okay and let's see if
that worked
all right cool so let's add some to dues
and the count goes up right because we
have now two undone to do is three M two
dues and as I check them that should
bind to the is own property on each
to-do item and you can see that the
count automatically goes down so those
are raiser components data data binding
in action now we're not we're not
showing up in our layout yet that's kind
of dissatisfying how can we fix that
well RAZR components also support
layouts layouts in racer components are
also components so the way you define
the layout is using a special kind of
component to call the layout component
and I there's one in this app that
defines that like left bar and all this
nice stuff if we look in the shared
folder there's this main layout
component it is itself also a component
the thing that's special about it is it
derives from this layout component base
and what that gives us it gives it this
body property which basically captures
the inside of the component wherever
that layout gets applied the content of
the thing that I got applied to is then
renderable using that body property so
this is saying you know render a nav
menu thing looks like that's another
component and then also render the main
page with some styling using bootstrap
and then put the the main content here
that's how layouts work in racer
components how do you apply that layout
to then to your components well you use
a new directive that's this at layout
directive here I'm saying I want to use
the main layout in this particular case
that's being specified in a view imports
file so it gets applied to all of the
components that are hierarchically down
that that that particular path okay so
we need to then modify our layout to add
that to do page to our to our
application
now the looks like that sidebar is
actually defined in this separate
component this nav menu let's go look at
that okay so there's a little bit of
code here but it's pretty
straightforward it's basically just an
unordered list of list items that you
have these nav link things in there
those are essentially anchor tags that
change their styling depending on
whether the current address matches the
link for that for that anchor tag so we
just need to add one more of these to
make our to-do page show up so let's add
one that's called put the href as slash
to do that was the
address that we set up in the page
directive and then over here let's make
some friendly text it would be just to
do alright and so now if we run this we
should have it to do page yeah so
there's a to do page over there on the
left and that has all the same
functionality that we had before all
right so that's layouts that's sort of
an introduction to razor components and
what razor components can do it's kind
of kind of interesting I hope I hope you
think it's interesting but some of you
I'm sure as you were watching that you
were probably thinking like wait a
minute isn't this just blazer like I'm
sure some of you have heard about blazer
before if you haven't blazer is this
experimental project that we've been
working on in the a speed on that team
to try and get dotnet to run directly in
the browser on top of web assembly you
don't know what web assembly is web
assembly is this new open standard that
was defined by the w3c community group
and it's basically a low-level byte code
for the web browsers no longer just run
JavaScript they can run anything that's
compiled to this new format called web
assembly and all the modern browsers
support it including mobile browsers and
desktop browsers and so we've been
working for a while on trying to get
dotnet to run on top of web assembly
really well in the browser and that
experimental project is called blazer as
part of that we've also built a UI
framework and it had components and
about a year and a half ago at an NDC
not not unlike this one Steve Sanderson
was actually here today some in the
front row did a demo sequence not unlike
what you just saw and it was blazer
running you know dotnet code its
components running directly in the
browser so is that what this is is this
just blazer but with a new name and the
answer is yes and no it's not quite that
simple because there's a bit that's
shared between both and that's really
what Razer components are all about so
in a blazer application if you haven't
seen blazer before it looks kind of like
this you have web assembly you know that
core capability of the browser if you
took a pile of some code to web assembly
you can run it in any browser at near
native speeds and then for blazer we
wrote a little dotnet runs
in webassembly that you can just
download to the browser and use to
execute dotnet assemblies directly in
the browser it's pretty cool on top of
that we then built this you wife simple
UI framework based on components and
those components are RAZR components now
with the a spinet core 3 oh release
we've done something a little
differently
those Razer components actually don't
have to be executed in the same process
where the UI is being rendered they
manage an in-memory representation of
the UI that they're updating and it does
a fancy diff algorithm for like the UI
that was updated previously with the new
new set of UI and figures out what's
different and then there's a process
that the runtime takes care of for
applying those UI changes to whatever UI
system you're using in this case
typically the Dom but what that means is
because the rendering logic of the Razr
components and how the UI actually gets
updated are separate you can run those
razor components pretty much wherever
you want in fact you can run them on the
server and that's what we've done in
dotnet core 3 oh we've taken the
component model that we started with
Blaser and we've now shipped the
component model in dotnet core and we
are going to support initially running
those components server-side on top of
the dotnet core runtime with your
application all the UI updates then get
handled over a real-time connection of
signal R of course that's the real time
time framework that we use in asp.net
core so the thing that's the same from
what you just saw is that yeah
everything I just showed you those were
Razer components they can run
client-side in the browser on web
assembly or alternatively which is what
I was showing they were actually running
server-side in an asp.net core app and
then all the UI updates were all
happening over a signal art connection
let me show you a little bit more about
how that's working so that you can
understand what's really going on there
so raise your components client or a
server so I'm going to switch to a
different app it's really the same app
that was what we just saw slightly
different bits just because the the new
razor components work that we doing in 3
Oh
a lot of that was just trying to get
bits moved over and working there's
still like a feature or two that makes
this particular demo a little bit harder
with the current preview it will get
better as we move forward but this app
does almost exactly the same thing as
what you saw before it has a to-do list
page it has encountered has a parameter
I just get it up and running so that we
can see it working and I got so many
tabs open now let's close all the other
tabs
okay so we have counter that's working
fetch data that's working on the two
lists we can add to dues and it does
exactly what it did before now let's
let's look at how this application is
actually working on the wire and let's
make this a little bigger so we can see
and then I control f5 so first of all
how big is this applicable today there
he goes
oh wait wait that was that was the
second state of the app that we were
supposed to see that yet you didn't see
that go back you forgot to reset this
demo okay okay
all right let's refresh this again all
right great that looks much better is
like why is it taking so long to load so
first thing yeah well it's actually
interesting like as I hit f5 that this
app actually loads pretty fast it's not
downloading very much into the browser
to get all that functionality if you
look down in the left hand corner this
app is about 100 kilobytes and that
includes bootstrap and all the other
stuff that it's using to make the UI I
look pretty but what actually gets
download in terms of artifacts well
there's HTML there's bootstrap there's
that server j/s script that kind of gets
everything up and running and at the
bottom you can see here there's this 101
switching protocols Network item what is
that that's basically setting up a
signal our connection with the server
its setting up a WebSocket connection in
fact if we double click on that and
single clicked on that in chrome we can
even see the the current frames that are
being passed back and forth between the
client and the server let me let me
clear it and then as I click on things
notice that frames start to show up you
see that and there they're not very big
like these numbers are in like bytes so
the amount of data that's actually going
back and forth over that connection is
very small but every time I click this
click Me button
what that's actually doing is it's
sending a notification to the server
saying hey someone clicked this button
and then the counter component executes
on the server it runs it's rendering
logic the runtime figures out what UI
needs to be updated it figures out that
diff it C realises the diff back down to
the the browser and then that little bit
of server Jas JavaScript applies it to
the UI that's how this razor component
app is working this is asp.net core
razor components razor components hosted
on the server but the same razor
components can also be run client-side
directly in the browser on web assembly
using the blazer model and that's pretty
easy to do we can just take this same
app same code same you know DLL that
you're compiling and change it to be
back to a web assembly based application
so I'm just going to change this
bootstrapping script and then we'll
refresh the browser again and that's now
we're gonna really see that slightly
longer load time because we're pulling
down a lot more with this application if
we look at the network trace it's
actually um yeah let me do one thing to
make it a little smaller because that
one looks a little surprisingly big
because we turned off linking for the
server-side mode I'm gonna at this and
let's turn this back on to true and I
think that should be fine and we'll be
in a build and rerun it again so that
one property what that's gonna do is
when the application gets built the
built assemblies are going to be run
through an IO linker to strip out all
the unused il because in the client-side
model your DLL actually goes down to the
browser so let's see first let's make
sure it's working still yep looks like
it's still working we got a fetch data
page and now if we look at the network
after refreshing okay so now it's a
little bigger it's two megabytes that's
not that's not a lightweight application
it's pretty cool considering that this
application now is downloading a full
dotnet runtime but yeah it's that's
that's that's what you get now so but
nice thing about this application is
it's running fully client-side in the
browser it doesn't actually require any
dotnet on the server at all this app
could run offline it could be a PWA and
you can leverage the browser for compute
and for resources and all the
functionality that
the browser can do so same raiser
components running client-side in the
browser on web assembly which is what
we're seeing here like your DLL is in
the browser or running server-side in
asp.net core for those of you who may
not believe that this is actually you
know dotnet code running in the browser
we can do one other thing and this this
demo is always a little bit dicey
because of the debugging support for
client-side blazer apps is uh you know I
work in progress shall we say but there
is a way to do it so if you go into the
console you can see there's this
debugging hotkey
shift alt D that's a special gesture in
the blazer a client-side blazar app to
say I would like to try and debug this
app in the browser now the way that
works it's works through the v8
debugging protocol we actually set up a
little debugging server in between
chrome and the chrome dev tools that
augments the protocol with dotnet
specific content okay so if I do a shift
on that control shift alt D so in order
to make that work chrome actually needs
to be running in remote debugging mode
the app will detect like oh hold on
you're not actually running in that mode
yet here's how you do it so I'm going to
copy the command that it's telling me to
do and the curl close down all of the
chrome instances and then let's just run
the command that it told me to run that
will start chrome in remote debugging
mode for the same application and then
let's do that again shift alt D
hopefully now we'll be able to connect
to our little debugging proxy which is
able to connect it to Chrome so let's
pull this out into a separate window
like so and you'll see over here in the
the chrome tool it's kind of small but
there there's a DLL showing up in the
chrome debugging tools along with all my
CS HTML for all my components if I go to
the counter page and then let's open up
counter CS HTML I can actually see the
code and then I'm going to set a
breakpoint right here on the increment
count method you see that and then as I
click Boop we just hit a breakpoint in
c-sharp code running directly in the
browser on webassembly so that's pretty
cool so it is in fact running clients on
the browser and it's the same razor
component model server or client and
let's just let this continue on through
I think it's one of the FA
yeah there it goes all right awesome so
that was switching between client and
server okay
so when would you use razor components
particularly on the server like when
when would you do that
when is this model compelling what are
its benefits and its drawbacks so the
things that are actually really nice
about razor components on the server
besides the fact that you just can write
c-sharp code and get that rich
interactive field well one of the
benefits is that the client is very thin
like you're only downloading that
JavaScript code that's that's provided
for you that sets up the signal our
connection sends the UI events up to the
server and applies any UI discs that
gets sent back so it's a very thin
client the app reloads really fast you
don't need a lot of functionality in the
browser in order to get that to run you
know you don't need a browser for
example that supports web assembly you
could do this in older browsers you
could do this in browsers where are our
devices that maybe don't have a great
internet connection and so doing that
initial download to have the app start
up when you're doing blazer is less
desirable so it's a much thinner client
it runs on dotnet core on the server so
you have the full runtime you can use
all of your your libraries and existing
assemblies you get all the functionality
of that runtime you saw that I was able
to just set breakpoints in vs and hit
those directly in my dotnet code that's
because it's just normal dotnet also
it's a bit of a simpler architecture
because your components are actually
running server-side then you don't have
to do like a hop through a web api layer
in order to get to some functionality on
the back end you're already there so if
you wanted to like go make a call to
your database or do server-side specific
stuff you can do that and we found that
actually appeals to quite a few doves
who have looked at this model
particularly folks who are concerned
about not wanting their code to leave
the server I mean with a blazer app your
D levels actually go down into the
browser and anyone can grab them and you
know just assemble them and see what's
inside
with the Razr components model on the
server all your code stays on the server
and no one
and then see it the downsides of this
model are of course well there's no
offline support this the UI works by
having that live connection so if you
need an offline app then this probably
isn't the the model for you you're not
going to be implementing a PWA
using razor components server-side also
there is a latency concern because
you're doing all the UI interactions
over a real-time connection for apps
where your data center is really close
and you have a really good solid pipe
that that probably isn't a concern at
all we've done deployments where we've
taken this major component app and like
deployed it to the US while we're here
in Europe and I initially thought that
that would be like clue and then the UI
updates but actually it's not bad like
you click there's a little bit of lag
but it's it's pretty good like remember
when we saw in the the frames for the
WebSocket connection not much data is
actually being sent for each of those
events so it is pretty quick you only
really limited in some sense by the
speed of light lastly a downside is that
you're you're using your server
resources now to run the app you've got
to keep all these persistent connections
you have to maintain the state of the UI
on the server you're not able to farm
out all of that compute on to other
people's browsers so you're kind of
paying for that but if that's what you
want and then that can be a really
compelling thing so a sort of a drive
home the the benefit of keeping its
server side of running the Razr
components on the server let me let me
show another app this was written by a
by Steve which is pretty cool
application this app actually uses Razer
components with ml net people heard of
ml net let me go back to the browser for
a quick second if you go to net at the
top we probably noticed that there was a
second banner where we're advertising
this ml net thing that's machine
learning net it's a machine learning
framework in written net code you can
train models you can do predictions all
sorts of cool fancy AI stuff with with
that framework all in net and c-sharp
code so the scenario here as least as
Steve explained it to me was he figured
out that when you have comments on like
your your your company's website or on
your product it's it's generally better
for business
those comments are positive or good so
wouldn't it be great if you could do
some sentiment analysis on the comments
and keep although you know the nasty
negative ones out and only keep the good
ones so maybe we could use ml net to do
that to do some sentiment analysis so
that's what this happened does let me
see if it's running okay so we have same
map as before but now we've got this
review page alright cool so I want to be
able to type in some text here and have
some sentiment analysis happen and then
we're going to move that slider back and
forth depending on how positive or
negative it is and this is gonna be used
during using a trained model but that
model is that's that's proprietary that
that's my IP like I don't want that like
bleeding down to the the browser for
anyone to grab and then reuse and I lose
my my competitive advantage I like to
keep it on the server so this would be
great we can just use razor components
on the server we can run the ML dotnet
code there and it never get makes it
down to the browser we can see that in
the code if we look at this application
let's look at its pages it has this
review page like we just were looking at
and let's see what it does it has this
update score method and it calls this
sentiment class and asks it to predict
now that class is implemented over here
and where's that predict method there it
is down at the bottom and here we're
actually loading up a real ml dotnet
model that's this sentiment dot zip file
and using it to calculate you know how
good or how positive or negative was
this text if it's zero you know that's
like the the dredges of human despair
like you're just just just horrible you
know absolute negativity wherever it's
one you know complete human ecstasy so
let's see if this works this is horrible
I hate it I will never use it again okay
okay whereas this is great
I love it alright we'll use it so you
get the idea and all that all that code
is running server-side only thing that's
being sent down to the client are those
UI diff to like you know move the slider
around and to the server we're sending
each of those keystrokes in that text
box as I type that was I don't know if I
showed that the event handling yeah on
input was the event that were handling
and it's just pointing to again a
c-sharp code okay so that's you know the
benefit of keeping it server-side how we
doing for time how we do okay so another
thing that's cool about Razer components
is that they're reusable and you can
build them into class libraries and it's
a RZR component that's CS HTML file what
happens when you do a build is it just
gets turned into a normal dotnet class
it's just a class that gets built into
an assembly and then run either on the
server or download it into the the
browser in the case of blazer on run on
the client so you can take those class
libraries and just ship them as NuGet
packages as reusable component libraries
and then when you're building your
application you can reuse component
libraries that are being built and
shared by the community I have another
app here that has a component library
let me pull it up think it's this one
all right so this application again
written by my my friend Steve Sanderson
see the wonderful thing about PM is that
you get to work with tabs and they they
write all the cool stuff and then you
just get to show it it's a great job
it's awesome so Steve wrote this this
component library for material design
people people familiar with material
design is a design paradigm for web
applications or UI I believe it's from
some some other company that shall not
be named but it still it's a cool stuff
you know styling and things so this is
not the round where is it today
razor components that's that's not it
that was the app I just did the demos oh
that's not confusing at all I had one
project name demo or one brother named
demos okay that was the one we were just
messing around
with all right so this product this
solution will has has several projects
it's got a razer component app and then
it also has just a class library project
with a bunch of component definitions
that are basically material design
components so here's the solution we can
just take a look at that so again we
have that server project that's the
hosting a speed on that core project we
have dot app that's where we're putting
all the the Razr components for our
application and then we have just a
class library a reusable class library
full of razer components for us to use
and you could package this up as a new
get package and share it with your
friends and so we've got things in here
like a material design button the check
box dialog and so forth if we go ahead
and run this app we can see these
material design components in action all
right there we go and so we got a slider
on the Left we have the counter for like
before but these that's a material
design button
here's layout and I I don't recognize
any of these books but I hear that these
are fairly popular kids books is that
does anyone like no Hairy Maclary I'm
told I'm supposed to read this to my
kids so if I find it get that from the
library at some point we have a
validating form here implemented using
material design so let's say I have a
kitten named fluffy but that I decided
let's and it's a British Shorthair but I
do not accept the kitten terms oh all
kittens must accept the terms no
exceptions so let's meet that again and
then we're good so what does that all
look like well it's there these are just
components so you use them using the
normal component syntax if we go into
that there I wanted to look at pages and
let's look at Vincent Beinecke on
display the cascading validation numbers
yeah so kitten breed is an MVC select
and we have a tendancy text field so
we're just reusing those components and
we didn't have to do any work that was
great and so the community actually has
been building out a lot of reusable
components that you can download as
NuGet packages off of the new georg if
you go to this case you're going to go
to blazar down that just because that's
where a lot of the community effort has
been happening recently but all ah this
these it again with blazer the
are still razer components so they still
apply there's a list here that we
maintain of libraries that have been
built by the community that you can just
use like for example there is somewhere
on here I was like a bootstrap one yeah
bootstrap blazer strap has a bunch of
reusable bootstrap components I think
there's like a charting component up
here oh there's a grid grid component
reasonable grid component with blazer so
lots of good stuff that the community
has been working on that you can just
use if you guys build any feel free to
let us know we'll add it to this page
even recently uh I mean component
vendors have been getting into the game
I think was telluric telic blazer
preview the guys at progress or telluric
they recently announced that they've
been working on their own blade blazer
and razor components and you can get a I
think it's a what they got a grid where
is it down here let me have a grid in a
tab view yeah so there's a kendo kendo
grid all written in with sheesh our code
and dotnet running running in the
browser or our server-side and in Razer
components they have a tab view here as
well so that's the beauty of
composability and usability you can then
build components and then use them in
your application now there's a couple
things in this this particular app that
are kind of interesting that I thought I
would show there's some features of
Razer components that I didn't show
earlier let's look over here first at
this jeaious Interop page so from your
Razer components that are running on the
server if you need to or want to you can
actually call down into JavaScript
that's executing in the browser so let's
say as part of your UI you want to call
some browser API or maybe you have a
JavaScript library that you know for
better or worse you you implemented
awhile back and you've got to use it or
there's one from the ecosystem that you
you need to or want to reuse you can
load that script in the browser and have
your razor component call into it
basically as if it was written in
c-sharp okay so let me show you what
that looks like so when I when I click
this call prompt button notice that
that's actually popping up a javascript
native prompt in the browser tell us
about your childhood it was great
and if I click okay then there's like
just popping up the local time in a
dialogue again a JavaScript call how is
that done if we go back to the demos app
and let's look at the JavaScript Interop
page so in raiser component applications
and also plays wraps you can get this
ijs runtime abstraction and that's a
service that you can use to then call
into javascript now notice it's being
injected into this component components
can have services injected into them
through through di those services
typically get configured in your startup
class just like they would in an asp.net
core application so here in start-up
where this step is adding its own
services the ijs runtime is one that we
provide for you all right so once you
have that service then you can use it to
do invoke a sink the the generic
parameter is the type of the return
value that you want to get back from the
JavaScript world and then the first
thing you pass is which function do you
want to call and this is basically like
a dot separated path relative to the the
global Windows object in JavaScript land
and then you just pass whatever done at
parameters you want to pass into into
JavaScript in this case it's even taking
a dotnet object so we're wrapping it in
a reference handing it off to JavaScript
so that JavaScript code can then call
back into dotnet so we can go both ways
you can call into JavaScript and even
have JavaScript call you back that's
useful for things like callbacks and
events that are happening in the
JavaScript world so let's look at this
particular function I think it's I had
to move it over here so in our group
folder somewhere here demos
it's like demos show prompt there's the
JavaScript function that we're calling
to show our prompt and this is another
JavaScript for some some other parts of
the application so you can write any
JavaScript you want anything that you
can do in JavaScript you can do from
from razor components oh yeah the other
thing I want to show here was template
components so here's an interesting
feature with with with components if you
if you have a component but you need to
pass it not just like a static parameter
but you actually want to pass it some
like a block of UI to say you know when
you render yourself here's how I want
you to render this particular part you
know think about like grids or list
views where you want to say for each
item in this list or for each cell in
this grid this is the UI I want to put
there you can do that with with racer
components - and those are called
template components so this dialog is
it's a little dialog that pops up and it
has a bunch of UI elements like there's
this block of UI at the bottom for what
actions you want to happen and then
there's the body of the dialogue let's
look and see how that that component is
implemented let's go to I think it's
super dialogue shared yeah this one okay
so here's super dialogue component and
it takes some normal parameters like
before like it's just taking the title
for the the dialogue box but it takes
these other interesting things - it
takes these parameters that are of type
render fragment and render fragment of T
that's basically a type that captures
that snippet of UI that the component
can then use to render some wherever it
wants on the page so in this case it's
capturing a parameter for the body
content and rendering that in a
particular spot and because it's a
render fragment of T you can even pass
some data to the the template and have
it haven't used to render and then we
have just a normal render fragment
without any parameters that we're
rendering for the the buttons content at
the bottom to see how that is then used
when you call that super dialogue here's
how we're specifying the body content
and there's that block of UI that were
that we're saying which should be
rendered into the middle of the dialogue
that was a this section here hurry up so
you know item and then it's using that
parameter to figure out what its name is
and whether it's in stock and then at
the bottom the the the set of actions
the set of buttons that are at the
bottom are again being passed in to the
component to say this is these are the
buttons that I want you to put at the
the bottom of the UI so that's template
component so you can build some pretty
high-level advanced components with this
model
okay now let's talk a little bit about
scale with the razor components model
remember we have this signal our
connection that we have to maintain in
order for the UI to be updated in order
for it to be functional now maintaining
lots of concurrent connections to your
application it's actually bit of a
tricky problem it's not super easy to do
there are patterns you could set it up
yourself but there's a bunch of
considerations when you have to scale
out to a whole bunch of connections it's
non-trivial fortunately azor actually
provides a service called the azure
signal our service that makes it pretty
much trivial to handle thousands of
concurrent connections I want to show
you that really quick because that's a
useful thing when you're building a
razor components application
so let me which one is this one this is
too many vs is open now let's close a
couple of them before I run out of
memory we want to do the azure signal
our razor component demo this way
alright so this app done a little bit of
tweaking to it it has a counter
component my goal with this app is I
wanted to SEP an app where there's a bit
of a story behind this I I sometimes go
and see what my kids are doing on the
computer you know the Mike my kids love
to play on the computer playing the
games or whatever and I figure it's it's
good every now then to peek at what
they're actually up to and I noticed one
day that they were playing this game
where there was like this I don't know
there's like a platform and there's this
monster or creature on it and they're
just tapping this screen as fast as they
can like this I'm like what are you
doing like Daddy we're playing a game
I'm like I'm sorry I was like okay and I
watched it for a while I was like so it
looks like the whole point of this game
is you just tap the screen as fast as
you can and they're like yeah it's great
super fun I'm like so I was like I have
to put a stop to this so I got forbade
this game for being played ever again
but you know it was intriguing to me how
compelling this was to them that you
know button I can just mash this button
as fast as I can and that's that's a
game so in this in this app what I did
is I took the the counter component okay
this is the counter component and it's
the
has down here at the bottom it still has
the account okay and we're checking
doing some time checking to make sure we
don't you know go outside of int max but
it's gonna increment the count every
time the button is pressed it was kind
of fun writing this particular demo
because it seemed like I was I was going
out of my way to violate every
architectural guidance that our
architect on the asp.net team David
Fowler recommend recommends like I have
a you know some static state up here now
for the for the current count you know
static so I can just see David Fowler
pulling out his hair and then we also
start a little polling loop for to just
loop over the UI and then check
basically say that the state of their
component has changed and that's so that
the component will send UI updates
periodically like five times a second so
that's so that as you click the button
every time you click the button normally
the page will refresh but let's say
something else changed that static state
well then you need something to let the
app know that it needs to update the UI
we don't actually have a push model to
like all the connected clients with
razor components we do use signal R but
it's basically your connection for your
client so this is a poor man's way to
have the UI sort of update automatically
all right so that was the app if we run
it you can just mash on the counter
component and then it displays a little
bit of you are now I wanted to publish
this to Azure and have everyone in the
room be able to mash on this and I
haven't I have not stress tested this at
all so this this this demo may fail
horribly but I did know at least that I
wanted to support a whole bunch of
concurrent connections so I enabled the
azure signal our service for this
application that was pretty simple I
just had to add a single package that's
this Microsoft Azure signal our package
so just go to new get and add that and
then in my startup file
I added signal R and the azure signal
our services to the application and then
down below I told Razor components hey
like don't don't don't use Sigmar with
don't take care of the hub by yourself
and that really should say components
hub we're gets a just one of those
renames we haven't gotten to yet don't
don't use the outer box a hug I'm going
to set that up myself because I want to
do something special
to set up the agile signal our service
and so over here we say use as your
signal our and then we set up the the
hub that's used by Razer components
manual ok
and then there's a connection string I
had to put in config but it's basically
you go to the portal you copy a string
and put it in your app settings alright
and then we just publish this to to
Azure so I've already done that and
let's see if this works I have no idea
if this is gonna work this might feel
horribly so that's good aka m/s counter
mash I think is what I put it at it's
gonna load ok so then you click the
button so if everyone wants to try this
might not work at all but uh oh my
goodness it's counting ok
what's working is it working
I'm counting sorry sorry yeah so if
people missed it
it's a KA dot M s slash counter mash
counter mash and see that ok let's see
let's see if this is gonna like blow up
the Apple II when we hit 100 we're 500
oh it's going fast keep going let's go
for let's go for max int but you get the
idea so I don't know how many people who
are connected but we're having lots of
connections now that are going to this
application and updating that count and
that's done what's that it's not loading
Oh blame it on the network and that's
through the beauty of the azure signal
our service so I look at my asher bill
later as that continues to go
that's the counter mash app maybe I'll
put some ads on there and show it to my
kids and make there to my kids friends
to make lots of map makes lots of money
ok we're almost out of time I think what
do we ask we uh yeah we got it's like
four minutes so the last thing I want to
show is you know the potential of Razer
components even beyond what we've
already seen so we've seen Razer
components running on the server we've
seen a little bit of Razer components
running and on the client on web
assembly there's gonna be a lot more of
that later today that's these stocks
that I highly encourage you to attend
but Razer components like I said they
can pretty much be run anywhere so one
of the experiments that we did was
running Razer components
with an electron tap so what if you
could write your UI using dotnet c-sharp
and then have that drive the electron
shell and now you basically have a
cross-platform desktop app written with
dotnet would that be cool so the way
that looks is something like this in
this case you can probably imagine this
happening one of two ways you can
imagine the Razr components actually
running on dotnet on webassembly
directly in the chromium shell that
makes up electron but that's not
actually how the the sample I'm going to
show you works in R in this case of the
Razr components are actually running in
a dotnet core process which is then
talking to electron over an IPC channel
so you actually have full net the full
performance and all the functionality of
dotnet core that's then driving an
electron application that's how this
sample works and I'll just show you that
one really quickly
before we wrap up talk a little bit
about roadmap so this sample is actually
publicly available on github it's on
Steve's github account so Steve
Sanderson MS plays electron experiment
sample you can find that on github and
I'm just gonna dotnet run this
application dotnet run if you're
familiar with dotnet core that's how you
start up a dotnet core process which is
what it's doing and then that dominant
core process is firing off on electron
process which it sets up an IPC channel
with and there we go alright so this now
is not a browser this is a lecture on
application but with the same UI that
you saw previously so this application
is now a cross-platform desktop app that
you can run on Windows Mac or Linux
using web technologies and dotnet so it
just gives you an idea of some of the
things that are you know potentially
could come down the road with the Razr
components model and you're welcome to
go download that sample and try it out
ok last little bit is roadmap like when
is all this stuff coming when can you
actually use it you know for a long time
the story there was it's experimental
don't put it in production I know you're
doing it anyway but don't you're not
supposed to put it in production you
know
we're not sure how the where this is
gonna go but that this story not with
Razer components is different Razer
components is shipping in dotnet core 3
oh it's already in preview 2 that's the
first preview it showed up with if you
have preview 1 that's not good enough
you got to go get preview 2 and we're
gonna continue working on it and
iterating on the model throughout the
dotnet course Ryo release when Dominic
Horace Rio ships
you have now a stable release of Razer
components that you can use and put in
production and it'll be fully supported
because the Razer component model is
being shared with blazer we will ship
updates to blazer with each dotnet core
3 all updates so we just shipped preview
- I think we're shooting for probably
early next week to have the next blazer
update blazer 0.8 is when we hope to get
that out and then have with when preview
3 if dotnet course Rio comes out will
expect to have another blazer update now
we don't expect actually blazer to ship
with Dona course Rio we expect it to
ship sometime later and that's the part
that's still not known we do intend to
ship it we just don't have a concrete
timeframe and roadmap for that quite yet
as soon as we do we will let you know
and I will have a huge party that's
gonna be super exciting so that's that's
the timeframe that we're looking at when
is dotnet core 3 o going to actually
ship I think we're looking probably in
the fall is when that will stabilize if
you've been following that release the
big work item there is that we're
bringing desktop support to dotnet
course REO support for WinForms and WPF
they're working really hard to try to
get all the designers working and that's
they that's a lot of work so we just
have to see how long that takes but it's
looking like maybe in the fall is when
that will go out so here's all the stuff
that we saw with Razer components we saw
parameters and event handling and data
binding and dependency injection routing
I think we almost got through everything
here I think we didn't see cascading
parameters so there's still more stuff
that you can go to the docks and check
out if you want to learn more make sure
you download and install the the SDK so
you can try it out you will need the new
version of Visual Studio it doesn't work
in 2017 the tooling is built in to 2019
here's a bunch of additional resources
if you want to learn more all the code
is in the main asp.net core repo that's
for both blazer and Razer components the
docks right now I'd recommend going to
blazer dotnet we're right now in the
process of moving all the components
specific stuff into the main a spinet
core docks
we taught a workshop earlier this week
on using razor components in blazer and
I it's a it's a public github repo that
you're welcome to go take a look at we
built a cool Pizza Store app if you want
to try out the workshop that's at AKMs
slash believes our workshop the
community page again for if you want to
get component libraries or JavaScript
Interop libraries and by all means
please join the conversation on get er
now don't miss Steve's talk and just
like you know a little bit later today
Get Set what 140 140 in room one in room
one if it's what I think it is now now
for those of you who don't remember like
it was at an NBC just like this that
blazer was born and you know it was it
was a complete surprise like like Steve
was with like pregnant with this blazer
baby and he didn't tell anybody about it
was it like I was talking to Richard
Campbell of dotnet rocks and he said he
was there and saw David Fowler who's you
know architect on our team when Steve
first show this and he said that David
had to like hold in his brain because it
was blowing up because he couldn't
believe what he was seeing so who knows
what we're going to see in Steve's talk
later today I highly encourage you to go
if he asks you why so many people are
there you can just tell them well well
Steve we heard that you are expecting to
show us something great and that's all I
got for you today thank you for being
here
there's some green card green cards just
lots of green cards out there on the
tables and thank you everyone for being
I'm happy to stick around to answer any
questions that you might have